thank you very much Jeff for that
quite touching introduction
and the Very moving little biopic it's
the most curious experience
to sit there let me turn the tables
pretty much straight away
after such a wonderful thanks for me to
thank my Karsten crew it's always those
two words I really think it should be
just the crew because whether you're in
front of the camera or behind we're all
in the same team
go
I've been reading a recently I've sort
of drawn back to reading about explorers
and and and people sort of taking great
Journeys and I've always interested in
the Shackleton story there where there
were ships crushed in the ice to the
Antarctic and the cruise stranded and
Shackleton goes off in a little boat to
bring back a rescue ship
and I think you know making these films
I like analogies a lot and I I do think
it is like a kind of Journey and that
you are putting a crew together
and you know they're going to get be
under stress at certain times
not just physical but emotional stress
as Jeff described that strange moment
where he he just lost it which every
major actor I have had including
Harrison Lawson at some point because I
think the atmosphere can get so um
strong the emotion that and there's so
much is demanded of the central
character that they're liable to sort of
just say I've had enough
so I'm very understanding I even wait
for it
but it's only momentary it's only a
passing thing uh but back to sort of
putting your crew together
I mean one you want Talent you want
people who know the job
um then you also want people
who can handle a tough and tight Corner
a difficult situation that will come up
uh you want to be able to trust them
so in a funny kind of way I don't cast
people in in you know the grips
Department with the department heads no
way back to Australia that I'm very
interested in the people they're putting
together in their Department
and back in the early days with smaller
Crews
I got so sort of sensitive to it that I
could say to Russell Boyd my cameraman
I'd say you know about you know I want
to use gaffer or something what's the
matter with Manza today
you know I could feel he wasn't with us
you know he was being grumpy
and he said you know he's got a family
problem I said can you have a little
chat with him let's let's get him back
with us because I think a group of
people doing something does create a
a kind of energy it goes around and
and so I love that and my crew always
knew that it was not about my eager or
their ego it was about the film's ego
the film has an ego and we're there to
serve it the best we can
so some of my good friends and good and
crew and Caster here tonight uh so
lovely to shake your hands again
thank you thank you
it makes me think of those those
important people I've worked with who
are not with us no longer with us
I think of Duncan Henderson and he was
my you know production manager we worked
together firstly on Dead Poets and he
went through to Master and Commander in
the way back many other firms but but
particularly complex film with its ships
and its battles
Duncan carried the weight of that
picture across his broad back
and then I think of Norman Lloyd who
played the Headmaster in Dead Poet
Society passed away recently
106. I believe
uh I stayed in touch with him after the
picture and got to know him sit at his
feet literally
because his he was like a walking
film
history you'd work with Orson Welles and
his great friendship with pitch
as an actor firstly then in Hitchcock's
hour as co-producer
lunch on Sundays with John Renoir
he knew everybody
and he wasn't a boar a very unusual
thing about someone who could tell the
story you know it's a he doesn't say had
I told you this before and he'd ask me
questions what are you doing and so so
it was a friendship
uh he even sent me a script that he
thought I might be interested in
something he'd had it used to be said it
was passed around at the Algonquin Club
he sent me the script he was a hundred
and said oh I think we could do this
together you know Peter Peter let's
[Applause]
and Robin Williams dear Robin
I if I could just have him back here
just for
five minutes that he could be here and I
I would say to him Robin I've got
something could you do something on
being in intimacy supervisor or
coordinator
it was amazing to watch him when there
wasn't a crowd around just two or three
people when he would
be seized by this inspiration and become
this sort of extraordinary character one
night very tired Sunday night
in the school hall where we filmed Dead
Poets waiting for the boys the real
students to come in we promised we'd
give Robin and I would give them a
little chat and thank them but Sunday
nights as you all know working in the
business when you're on a shoot
it's pretty precious you're getting
ready for the next day anyway we're
behind the curtain literally and I'd
look out every now and again no one said
I said to Robin do you really think you
can do this you know
he said hey yeah yeah and there was a
piano and on top the piano was a Bible
and I said why did you just read
something from the Bible you know I mean
save your energy
and he said the missing chapter a
missing chapter of the Bible
and they did roll off in the dirt and
cover themselves with dust and off he
went on a on a complete sort of King
James version of the Bible it was a
remarkable
briefly My Own Story falls into two
parts
um a filmmaker in Australia for the
first half a bunch of films and secondly
here in the United States
I was fortunate to be around when
our moribund film industry came to life
again
uh in the late 1960s early 70s
we knew nothing
but we were determined what we did know
is uh was about our love for movies
we had no older generation
that you could sit at the feet of and
ask them what it's like and what do you
do
but we did have film festivals and we
saw the best of world Cinema and so much
was happening here you know we'd get
your new John cassavetti's films and you
know coming from Europe and from Asia
there were still Giants roaming the
Earth at that time by Kurosawa monsters
uh so they were inspiring and then you
had a 16 mil camera you had bollocks and
you had a piece of paper you got a
repair and you could write your script
and get out there and shoot it actors
younger people were quite good the older
people were very difficult to work with
because they were theater trained
uh so on
my first feature I had a couple of these
older uh gentlemen
and so they might have a line like um
why don't you come in and sit down you
know this is the light so let's rehearse
it why don't you come in foreign
why don't we why don't we drop the line
and why don't you just point at the
chair
uh to which
dear old Eddie hell said there goes
another line
so in a strange way that earlier films
were silent for the very reason I was
cutting out dialogue
also we couldn't really write very well
I mean we were flying there with the you
know with very little experience but
what a way to learn there was no film
schools there was no one to tell you you
were wrong it was nowhere to tell you
what a dumb idea it was just go let's do
it
so I was there with a bunch of what
became friends some names you would know
became very very well known throughout
the world
and that was my life through the 70s
up into the early 80s
um baz luhrmann was coming along he's
here tonight
um
and I felt Restless I felt like I needed
new inspiration new Energy new
Landscapes different ideas I was ready
for change I was ready for Hollywood
so ever it came I'd read all the books I
knew I had to be very careful if things
went wrong then that possibility would
be canceled out I wouldn't do a second
time wouldn't have a second go
I'd go back and work in Australia
uh so my age and John Patek who was my
agent for all of these Hollywood
pictures John's here tonight and I want
to thank him
he guided me he guided me said it's
Casey he said you know he understood
that I'd been in a way running wild and
free in Australia with the independent
films and he knew that he had to get the
right people people that would match up
with me and would understand how I
worked and I could work with them and
introduce me to Jeff katzenberg
and Jeff what a great meeting Jeff
offered me Witness
and I went up and saw Harrison
chatted away and
it was wonderful uh he met me at the
airport which was quite a surprise I was
thinking I'd get a cab or something was
up in the mountains there he was he was
a pickup truck
I said yeah that's very decent though it
was world famous guy you know so we went
to the supermarket to get some supplies
going down the island that was his face
on the drawing on the box of the sort of
corn flakes or something and solo you
know
uh anyway we had a couple of great days
I came back to
um Jeff katzenberg and we shook hands on
it
and
if that picture had gone slightly
differently for example
about working with Jeff the end sort of
firm penultimate scene was that Harrison
was leaving the farm either she had to
go with him or he had to stay if they
had to part
and I'd hinted at Alexander good enough
who was his amishman would be her love
interest there were two pages of
dialogue not the same kind of situation
as I had in Australia but
I cut it cut the two pages out just
pulled them out of the script and I said
it's got to just be done with looks
because the audience doesn't understand
the thing by now then they never will
you can't stay she can't go
and uh dear Ed Feldman the producer said
Peter you signed off on the script you
can't do this in this country in this
studio with a Paramount
you have to film it
and I said no I can't it's not right it
doesn't work
um let me call Jeff katzenberg Jack to
his credit came in to see me
we went to dinner
and he said Peter you don't want to
choose why don't you shoot it and then
don't use it if you don't like it and I
said well what kind of direct is that we
go this way you know I mean you have to
have that's this is what will work and
um he reminded me that um when we first
met I told him the story I quite like to
do that sometimes I'll I like the verbal
side of it so I
I'll tell the story like an after dinner
speaker not a pitch
about eight nine minutes
uh and with all the visuals you know as
many as I know
you know so witness I told him I said we
open with a sort of field of wheat
blowing and bowing and figures coming up
through it with black hats and strange
fancies at fancy dress is it a period
film down the road they go Etc he said
remember you told me the story like that
why don't you describe the missing two
pages to me now how will it feel
and I said okay I'll back up a bit and
so they're in the restaurant you know as
I backed up to a couple of scenes and I
said he turns he looks he comes through
the thing you know this happened to that
she looks down she's worried she half
Smiles he picks that up with that
Harrison smile blah blah blah
I said sounds good
yeah go ahead
and when we did Dead Poet Society he
said before we started anything he said
come to dinner tonight
and before dinner tell me the story
and so I went to his house and then we
got up it was a glass of wine wow
it's the open that first day of school
that said
so I got off to a good start
and had a wonderful 20 years
of making Studio pictures
I love the history of it all
Serena talked about through Norman I was
delighted to be here you've got a such a
great industry
such a short history
I was thinking talking pictures aren't
100 years old I know we're going through
tremendous changes
you've done so much you've produced such
wonderful films and such wonderful
people and you're so welcoming to
foreigners like me
uh not never a word about there was a
little the joke earlier
about taking jobs well you know that may
be true or not but uh well I don't think
it's true there's too few of us uh
anyway so I would just finally like to
say to the Board of Governors
it's a sound I like very much it has a
sort of medieval Tang to it
you could have long robes with tassels
and sort of funny hats
in England you would
but you're elected you're all elected
you all represent
one of the branches that make up this
industry
and
I love craft I think that's what it's
really all about the outside of it leave
it to
leave it out
don't you love something that's well
made
whether it's a chair or a table or a
statue
so to all of you
thanks for adding my name to this
illustrious roll call of former honorees
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]